new memorial to pay tribute to those
four girls who lost their lives an
iconic moment in the civil rights
movement this statute dedicated
yesterday and not too far from that
location is Doug Jones who served as the
US Attorney for the Northern District of
Alabama during the second half of the
Clinton administration he was also part
of the panel we watched just a moment
ago mr. Jones thanks very much for being
with us my pleasure Steve thank you for
having me one of the questions we've
been talking about during the course of
our coverage is why it took so long for
those responsible to be prosecuted so
there were two instances in which you
paid close attention to what was
happening first during the trial in mr.
Chambliss and then later as the US
Attorney in northern Alabama so walk us
through those two moments
well it I think see that it took so long
simply because this was the first
bombing in Birmingham in which people
were killed I mean there were so many
bombings but this was the first bombing
in which people were killed and at the
time the Klan and all those who may have
known something about it just shut down
they clammed up the FBI did a phenomenal
job of investigating but like so many
thousands of homicide cases you can't
always prove them at time and it takes
some time to get through and in 1970 a
young Attorney General of Alabama took
over Bill Baxley and made it his mission
and finally in 1977 14 years after the
bombing bill brought a fellow named Bob
Chambliss known as dynamite Bob to
justice but he went out of office after
the Chambliss conviction and for 24
years it kind of sat dormant until local
FBI local Department of Justice
officials decided that the time was
right to take another look at it there
were a lot of things that had happened
in Birmingham over the years there were
a lot of things that happened around the
south including the convictions of Byron
de la Beckwith for the murder of Medgar
Evers in the conviction of Sam Bowers in
Mississippi for the murder of Vernon de
mer and that's when people began to
rethink this and say well you know what
we can take another look at this we can
go back and so I was just fortunate
enough to be at the right place at the
right time in a moment in time in a
moment in history when these cases have
been reopened and I took office and we
just took it from there and thank God we
were successful so let me bring up the
names of two other individuals that you
were directly responsible for their
conviction
Thomas Blanton jr. and Bobby Frank
cherry explained what led to those
convictions yes well there were two
different cases we ended up trying the
cases separately we wanted to try them
together but we had to separate them
there was an issue initially about
Cherry's competency and the two cases
ended up being very different in the
first case was the Blanton case and that
case consisted of some significant
evidence one from all of which really
came from the early 60s and during the
time there was a man named James Leigh
who was a volunteer with a civil defense
group he would just leave his day job he
was a postal worker
and he would leave his day job and ride
around the city with others to try to
protect the homes of the civil rights
leaders in the churches two weeks before
this bombing he's riding by 16th Street
Baptist Church right down 16th Street at
one o'clock in the morning and he sees a
car and that car was parked right
outside the steps that later blew up on
September 15th and there was a white man
standing by the car and there was
another white man standing over by the
steps that were where the bomb was
ultimately placed the man was by the
steps is holding what mr. Lai called a
grip
he hit his bright lights and they took
off but when the FBI talked to him about
it and by the way they call the police
and the police in typical fashion for
the day
don't him just your own homeboy you just
didn't see a damn thing and boy was the
name given to all black men in
Birmingham by the police at that time
but two weeks later he was near the bomb
he helped pull the bodies out the FBI
talked to him he identified two people
the man standing by the car he looked at
the pictures and picked out Bob
Chambliss who Baxley convicted and the
other man this man standing by the steps
holding the grip the satchel was Tommy
Blanton so that was a very significant
piece of circumstantial evidence that we
had even though mr. Lai had a stroke
right before our trial and we had to
read his testimony there was also a tape
recording that was made by the FBI after
Blanton got married and they they put a
little bog underneath his kitchen sink
and caught on tape a conversation with
him and his wife and one other person in
which Blanton was talking about that
weekend and where he was he was at the
Cahaba River and he was at this place
called their modern shine shop and they
were making the bomb and they were
planning the bomb the cherry case was so
much different it involved statements
cherry was his own worst enemy he would
lie to the FBI and brag about it he
would lie to law enforcement about where
he was in closing arguments after all of
these old FBI agents came and testified
we plotted out the inconsistencies about
cherry and his whereabouts that weekend
which was damning but most significantly
after this case became public after the
investigation our phone started ringing
when it went public
his granddaughter called an ex-wife
called there were three other people
that called that gave testimony about
Cherry's admissions over the years
really
bragging about being part of the group
that Bondish this church and killed
those little girls and this question why
why did they do it well you know Steve
that's a that's that's probably the
$64,000 question that really hasn't been
answered and probably never will be we
can all surmise we can all talk about
the fact that in the spring of 1963 the
church was the focal point of the mass
meetings and the children became the
symbols of the movement as much as dr.
King and Reverend Shuttlesworth and
Reverend Abernathy and so that they had
a target on their back there's no
question about that that the church and
the children had targets on them and the
obvious reason is because of their
involvement in the in the movement but
at the end of the day at the end of the
day one of the great regrets I have in
the case was not having someone step
forward someone who was involved someone
who wanted to get it off their chest to
take some responsibility to simply tell
us the story and apologize to Birmingham
into the world about what happened and
so the real Weir's and wise and whose
will probably never be answered three of
these people that we believe were
involved have gone to their graves the
fourth one is in prison today and is
likely also to go to his grave without
truly telling the story and and I I'd
give anything if the if the final
chapter could be from someone who was
actually involved to step up and to say
they're sorry and to tell us exactly
what and why the bombing of the church
happened in C 1963 Doug Jones is joining
us from just across the 16th Street
Baptist Church as we reflect on the
events from 50 years ago on this state
at 1022 local time a bomb exploded four
young girls were killed two others also
killed on this date and later today live
coverage of the ceremony that will
include former Secretary of State
Condoleezza Larrick Holder you can join
in on the conversation we welcome your
calls and comments at 2:02 585 3880 for
those of you in the eastern or central
time zones and for those of you in the
mountain or Pacific time zones 2:02 585
38 81 you can also join us on our
twitter page the hashtag c-span history
or on facebook.com and I'll share a
Facebook comment in just a moment but
first I want to go to Dorothy
who
on the line from Mobile Alabama go ahead
please good morning my question for mr.
Jones well first on the comet I really
respect and admire your work that you've
done but I've always wondered for for
someone of the white race to come and
actively be involved and take a stand
and recognizes this as long have you
yourself sir protected for any kind of
backlash from people in your own
community have you been rejected have
you been targeted because that was a
very great thing for you to have done I
just was curious about that well that's
a question I get all the time and I
appreciate you asking and the short
answer is no we never received a
backlash we never received any hate mail
the the lawyers and prosecutors in
Mississippi that did some of these cases
did receive some of that backlash bill
Baxley in 1977 received some backlash we
found nothing but general support
overall support in the Birmingham
community for these cases we did a lot
of jury work we did a lot of focus group
work and what we found was that people
supported these cases they didn't want
us to prove it you know try to indict a
case and bring somebody to trial unless
we had the evidence but if we had the
evidence everyone generally felt that it
was you know a wrong that needed to be
righted we heard a little bit of some
you know talk radio I think the worst
backlash with people who saying you know
we don't want to look back we just don't
like to see the fire hoses and the dogs
and I got to tell you we try two of
these cases one in May of 2011 and the
other one in 2012 and May of 2012 and in
between we had 911 and so the voices
that were a little bit vocal about why
are we going back and why are we
prosecuting these old men they were
pretty silent after 911 because it's
just I think everyone understood at that
point that it's just never too late to
kind of seek that truth and to seek that
justice so it's a question I appreciate
you asking very much where did you grow
up
I grew up in Fairfield Alabama which is
about eight or nine miles west of here
it was a very it was a very blue-collar
town it was a steel mill town US Steel
was out there it was probably I think
the second largest steel making facility
in the country second only to Pittsburgh
very blue-collar my family all worked in
the in the steel mills my community it
was a very suburban community in the
1950s in Glen Oaks Alabama it was as you
would expect a very segregated community
white schools and black schools white
churches and black churches it was not
until I went to junior high
in the late 60s that things began to
really change and all of this became and
to focus as my schools were desegregated
and for the first time in junior high I
was puttin in a school at Fairfield
junior high school with with black kids
and so it was a I you know I've thought
about this a lot Steve and I think to
some extent it was a generation of kids
who who were on the front lines during
school integration that helped make so
many of these changes and it it seems
appropriate that a child of my age could
grow up and finish the job that Bill
Baxley and others had started here it's
kind of that full circle of things and I
think the arc of justice bends that way
and unfortunately it did for us Doug
Jones we're looking at the scene behind
you this has really become a gathering
place for what has been a seminal moment
in the civil rights movement and that
statue dedicated over the weekend to
those four girls who lost their lives 50
years ago have you had a chance to talk
to family members and if so what are
their thoughts
I have stayed in touch with family
members over the years all of them they
you know I tell everyone as I speak
about these cases around the country the
strength of those cases were those
family members they didn't they didn't
do the kind of things that you often
expect in today's media world and social
media world these were just rock-solid
family members who had this abiding
faith in our system of justice and they
knew they just had this faith that
sooner or later justice would prevail
they were unbelievable people we've lost
a few of them we've lost Carol
Robertson's mom out for Robertson we've
lost Cynthia Wesley sister Eunice Davis
since that time the McNair family mr.
and Miss McNair are the only surviving
parents there are two sisters of the
McNair family Diane Braddock is here who
is the sister of Carole Robertson you
have two of the Collins sisters Addie
Mae sisters are here along with the
third sister Sarah Collins Rudolph who
is one of the most tragic figures of all
because she was the survivor
she was the filthy little girl in that
ladies lounge and suffered horrible
injuries and live has lived for the last
50 years not just with the grief of
losing her sister that she was close to
but with the pain of losing an eye and
still with with some glass shards and in
another eye these families are truly
amazing and as this week approached they
became more excited when you know I was
there with family members in the Oval
Office and watching the president the
United States the first African American
who told these family members that but
for their family sacrifices there's a
chance that he wouldn't be office he
pointed to the Attorney General and said
the same way to the Surgeon General and
to sitting in the halls of the US
Capitol to the other day watching
members of Congress Republican and
Democratic in a generally a polarized
environment to come together to talk
about with tears in their eyes the
sacrifices of these children this is a
special moment it is a special day and
time as we look back and as we look
forward and we're going to have coverage
of that Congressional Gold medal
ceremony that took place earlier this
year to pay tribute to those for who
lost their lives 50 years ago we welcome
your calls and comments here on c-span
threes American history TV
and I want to share a comment from our
Facebook page and you can weigh in at
facebook.com slash c-span history but
this is from one of our viewers who says
the horror of this event is not lessened
but intensified by the passage of time
to think that innocent children were
killed in a church as they prepare to
worship God shows the depth of hatred
that fueled such an act thank you all
who fought for the civil rights of
African Americans because no one's
rights are safe when anyone's rights are
denied your thoughts Doug Jones you know
Steve dad I appreciate that comment so
much and it reminds me of a comment made
to me by the father of Denise McNair
Chris McNair Chris McNair was a
photographer he had a studio here in
Birmingham for many years and when he
went in he had at his studio he had a
memorial room to Denise that had her
shoes her dresses and other things of
her childhood but also there was one
display that he kept in that display
case and when he went to the hospital to
walk into the makeshift morgue to
identify the body of then his only
daughter Denise he did so at at a point
when she still had a piece of mortar a
piece of concrete embedded in the middle
of her skull and one of the time I've
known the McNair family for many years
and I finally got up the nerve to ask
Chris one day about why he keeps that
and his answer was almost exactly the
same as the Facebook person who
responded that that is the reminder that
was the reminder that people mourn the
children they remember the events here
but when they see a piece of mortar
embedded in the skull of a beautiful
little black child then people realize
the depths that people will go in the
name of hate so I think it is something
to remember especially as I saya T
becomes more diverse especially as we
become ever more vigilant of acts of
terrorism we got to remember that
terrorism started at home right here in
Birmingham and other places around the
country not just the south and it is now
spread far and wide some other comments
on our Facebook page
/ c-span history this is from Lela
McGuire who says there is no
excuse for this kind of hate and from
Mary Lou Clemmons
special little angels and another saying
respect let's go to Reginald joining us
from Memphis Tennessee good afternoon
good afternoon how you doing sir I was
called in a very quick - quick question
first of all welcome in mr. Doug I mean
I'm 54 years old I never heard of you
but I want to thank thanks thanks for
the meeting you and I one has two quick
questions first question is do the Klan
still exist and also here in Memphis in
Maya city we have our two counties have
merged the city and the county have
mirrors and the school system is now
gonna be consolidated to one system and
so now they have up some people getting
together now and they want to stop the
other they want to have their own
separate school system so if that a sign
of racism or is that legal
counter to doose's they don't want to be
a part of the mirror system they want to
start their own municipal school
district and I'm sure your answer thank
you so much for taking my call Reginald
thanks for the call from Memphis first
question Doug Jones on the Klan well the
Klan does exist I don't think they exist
in the same form and fashion that they
did years ago thanks to great lawyers
like Morris Dees in the Southern Poverty
Law Center the they really broke the
back of the Klan years ago with a number
of lawsuits that were got filed you know
the interesting thing about today's
white supremacist they exist on the
Internet I think that is you know the
Internet is such a wonderful thing for
us but it also has its dark side and
there are hate sites on the internet
there are Klan sites there are white
supremacist sites that we have to
constantly I think shield our children
from and that's where they exist most of
the time you'll see a few meetings every
now and then but it's the it's the
Internet that is creating sometimes the
lone wolves out there that will incite
people to do harm you know it's
interesting about Memphis I'm fascinated
to hear that story because the same
thing happened in Birmingham years ago
fifty years ago there was an effort to
consolidate Birmingham with the other
municipalities and they refused to do it
primarily because of the of the school
system we've heard in our history
lessons this week and going back and
look when the Jefferson County school
system here
Jefferson County Alabama which is
separate from Birmingham first started
the desegregation orders and integrating
the schools some of the cities pulled
out at that point too and I think that
that's very unfortunate because I think
the diversity of our schools even though
it's it's very difficult to do these
days there's a de facto integration
desegregation I think around where
school systems stay predominantly white
in predominantly black I live in a
predominantly white neighborhood and so
my school system is predominantly white
and there's very little you can do about
that at this point I hope that the city
of Memphis will rethink this because
they can celebrate the diversity they
can uplift everybody and I think that's
the key is making sure all boats rise
with the tide and that's what I think
people have in mind when they're when
they're looking at merging the schools
in Memphis in the county fifty years ago
on this state Denise McNair who was 11
years old Carol Robertson who was 14
Eddie Mae Collins in Cynthia Wesley also
14 years old and here are their pictures
shortly before they were killed on this
state fifty years ago and you were in
law school when the trial of dynamite
Bob Chambliss was under way what do you
remember I remember a lot about that
Steve it was an amazing experience I'd
had the good fortune one time in college
to spend some time with a one of the
country's great jurist William O Douglas
and told me gave me a little advice that
if I wanted to be a good trial lawyer go
watch good trial lawyers go to trial so
you get a lot out you're sitting in your
law school class but you don't get near
as much at watching what was then the
trial of the century great lawyer in
with Bill Baxley on the prosecution side
and art Haynes senior and junior on the
defense side and I sat in the balcony
and I can remember watching Elizabeth
Cobb who was the niece of Robert
Chambliss and talked about the things
that Chambliss said before when he was
complaining about events that he saw on
television and said we just wait until
Sunday when they'll beg us to segregate
I remember watching
mrs. Glenn who came who was visiting
from Detroit in 1963 and identified
Tommy Blanton's car being behind the
church at two o'clock in the morning but
most significantly I remember the
closing argument that bill Baxley gave
that day as he laid the pictures of
these children that were taken in the
more on the jury rail and the emotion
and talking about that day of in
November 1977 how it would have been
Denise McNair's 26th birthday it was the
kind of it was the kind of emotion it
was the kind of event that that is
seared in your memory it makes you
understand why you've gone into law why
you understand that you're going to be a
lawyer
and it's just one of those events that I
just got it's hard for me as a as a
human being and as a lawyer to really
express how it's helped mold and shape
me over the next twenty four years
before I became the United States
Attorney carolyn McKinstry remembers
what happened 50 years ago she was at
the 16th Street Baptist Church in
Birmingham Alabama here are her
reflections what I remember when the
bomb exploded I remember not really
thinking that it was a bomb I the first
thought that I had was maybe that it was
thunder or something the sound maybe
think of thunder but as quickly as I
thought that the windows came crashing
in
and I heard someone inside the church
they hit the floor and when I fell on
the floor
I could tell after a few seconds I could
hear feet I could tell that people were
getting up running out so my first
thought was for those two younger
brothers that I had brought with me I
knew that before I could leave or go to
safety I would need to figure out where
they were and so I I went outside and
searched downstairs and upstairs and was
never able to find my brothers there at
the church we would find them later in a
different part of the community on this
particular Sunday we were very excited
all of the young people were excited
because it was used Sunday that just
meant that we were in charge of
everything we sang we gave the devotion
we did the ushering we did everything so
we were excited about that as I started
up the stairs to complete those reports
I passed the bathroom where my friends
were and I spoke to them and they were
combing hair and talking and just
everybody excited in their own way about
different things but I didn't linger
there because of the report and as I
started up the steps when I reached the
top the phone was ringing in the church
office in those days the church office
was right behind the sanctuary so when I
reached the church office and heard the
phone ring I went in and answered it
there's a shorter whom I worked under
was not there and the caller
male caller on the other end said three
minutes and as quickly as he said that
he hung up so I still had my items in my
arm my materials in my arm and I just
turned and walked out into the sanctuary
and only because we've counted it I know
that I took about 15 steps before the
bomb exploded
what was the last thing that you had
such them before you left them in the
bathroom see you later when I passed the
bathroom last thing I said see you later
from Carroll McKinstry who wrote the
book while the world watched a
Birmingham bombing survivor comes of age
during the civil rights movement from
book TVs coverage of the civil rights
movement and back live from the 16th
Street Baptist Church in Alabama Doug
Jones is joining us what was the bomb
made of and how was it placed just
adjacent to where you are that exploded
in the basement of that church well you
know Steve it's another one of those
unanswered questions the bomb was placed
underneath the bottom steps that led to
the back of the sanctuary there was a
door that was in the back of the
sanctuary and there were steps that led
down right across the large window that
led to the ladies lounge those steps
haven't been repaired they're not there
anymore it's a window and the steps have
were obliterated and have not been
repaired the bomb was placed right
underneath the bottom steps but one of
the great mysteries has always been what
was the bomb made of because the FBI
with all of their technicians they came
down they had boots on the ground within
minutes and certainly within hours
people from Washington DC were here at
collecting material but it was never
really determined all of the tests that
were made at the time could not
determine exactly what it was I think
that there is a very good chance it was
made of dynamite
12 to 14 sticks of dynamite dynamite was
very plentiful in Birmingham we had
several dynamite factories in Birmingham
it was not as controlled as it is today
so we believe it was dynamite but at the
end of the day we just could never prove
it one way or another we just know it
was a bomb and as you pointed out
Birmingham became bombing ham with more
than 50 bombs from the late 1940s
through the early 1960s did these
individuals responsible for the bombs
intend to kill
another great question you know for many
many years the theory behind the 16th
Street Baptist Church bombing case was
that it did not go off when it was
supposed to that no one was supposed to
get hurt there was some testimony about
that in the Chambliss trial there was a
little bit of testimony about that that
we had in the cherry trial where an
ex-wife and a brother-in-law of Cherry's
testified that he would on the one hand
say well the bomb didn't go off when it
was supposed to but at the same time he
would turn around and to show you the
kind of hatred and type of people we
were dealing with he would talk about
these beautiful little girls and say
well at least they can't breathe but at
the end of the day we didn't know one
way or another and I can always we were
fashioning our theory really not having
to determine one way or another whether
it went off when it was supposed to and
after Blanton and sherry were indicted
it was as you can imagine a great deal
of media here and they were released on
bond and when they got out on bond
awaiting trial there was a little bit of
disconcerning in the in the black
community here in Birmingham and there
was a lot of media of black leaders and
ministers who were complaining these
people had been off out free for
30-something years they should remain in
jail and so I called a meeting and I met
right here at the Civil Rights Institute
we were outside of today with a number
of the leaders because I was very
concerned that those kind of comments in
that media would cause a jury to be so
biased that we couldn't get a fair jury
and at that point I was asked a question
and I was asked a question by one of the
great leaders here reverend abraham
woods he asked me the same thing that i
believed that the bomb was meant to kill
people and i gave him the same history
lesson that i just said a minute ago and
he said well doc i'm really disappointed
to hear you say that because we believe
that with the march the children's
marches here in birmingham and the
desegregation orders that came about
with a school system because people do
forget that birmingham schools were
desegregated just days before this
bombing and with the march on washington
and the movement growing as it was the
Klan was unhappy and they were they were
just basically ignorant
people and the only way that they could
figure it out how to stop it was to do
more violence and to finally start
trying to do damage which kill people
and he reminded me of a bomb that took
place two weeks after this here on
Centre Street here in Birmingham and
there were actually two bombs one was a
decoy bomb that brought people out and
the second one was a shrapnel bomb
designed to kill people and so it became
our theory at that point that we
fashioned everything around the fact
that these children's marches put a
bull's-eye on the children they put a
bull's-eye on the church and the Klan
was unhappy and they decided that they
would kill people I don't know if it was
right or wrong
I dared some of the old Klansmen when we
talked to him to tell me I'm wrong
to tell me and you get on the stand tell
me what happened and he explained - am I
wrong not a single one of them ever did
so Steve that's my story and I'm
sticking to it
but there is an oath of silence among
members of the KKK can you explain well
there's an oath of silence which was it
was kind of interesting because if
anybody ever has ever gone through the
Klan files in the FBI you will knew
there was not only an oath of silence
but there were just replete with
informers I mean everybody want to kind
of stay personally in good with the FBI
and so yes there was a note of silence
and I think that oath really was drawn
in blood after the 16th Street Baptist
Church bombing we got very little help
there were informants yes and we had a
lot of informant information that
pointed to Cherry Blanton Chambliss and
others that may have been involved you
look at informant information that told
us that it was very planned that the
night before the bombing that all of the
clan leaders were very conspicuously
seen around Birmingham that night all
had their own alibis ready to go but at
when this bomb happened it clammed up it
shut up
and those people stayed silent whether
it was an oath or whether it was just
their own feelings of guilt and afraid
that they would to go to jail I don't
know but I do know this I know that
except for a couple of people that were
informants and that helped us in the
1960s we got virtually no help from
former Klansmen that we talked to that
I'm still convinced knew something about
this bomb
before or after it happened Doug Jones
served as the former US Attorney for
northern Alabama during the second half
of the Clinton administration we have
this tweet from one of our viewers Doug
Jones t says I thank you for your
commitment and bravery for prosecuting
the monsters behind the 1963 church
bombing you can share your thoughts the
hashtag at c-span history Michele is
joining us from Chester of Virginia go
ahead please thank you for having a more
kompis first of all my question to you
that you mentioned that you would like
for someone to speak regarding the
Klansmen you know to fill in the story I
wanted to know did the ex-wife or the
granddaughter are they able to fill in
the pieces because it would be nice to
have a complete a complete note of
history to fill in right no they didn't
fill in those kind of pieces they filled
in some interesting gaps for us because
of the admissions that were made the
ex-wife who came to Birmingham to
testify told us about a time when Bobby
Frank Cherry's car broke down just
outside the church and she came to pick
him up and he talked about where they
placed the bomb and there were other
times when he talked about the bomb but
they didn't fill in the gap she was not
married to him in 1963 so she didn't
know all of the details and he now I
don't think he ever shared the real
details about where the bomb was made
who was placed it and those kind of
things
the granddaughter and others mainly
talked about how a cherry after the fact
would brag about it she of course was
not born in 1963 either so it was the
bragging that took place afterwards that
I think helped seal the deal in the
Cherry case and and one other
interesting piece Steve that I wanted to
mention while we're talking about people
that talked about what sherry said in
1980 there was an individual who had
been from Birmingham that had moved to
Dallas Texas and he came forward when he
saw the media to tell us about a
conversation that he had with cherry in
1980 this is
twenty-something years ago almost 30
before the media showed that we had be
investigating the case and you told us
about a time when they were cleaning
some apartments in Dallas cherry had a
carpet cleaning business and they were
complaining people in the room were
complaining about the rise of the
Hispanic population in Dallas in 1980
and in 1980 even then Bobby Frank cherry
says but we just need to hand all the
mexicans like we did with and you can
imagine the racial slur that he used
talking about the black community in
birmingham alabama and so when we talk
about the lessons of history and and how
we need to remember the lessons of
history so that we don't make the same
mistakes i think that's probably the
most significant piece of testimony for
today's climate with all that we have
going on in our country with regard
immigration and the diversity that we
have tim is joining us Fort Wayne
Indiana welcome to the program Tim
thanks guys I had a couple quick
comments in a question I think the
church should be a historic site and
also a national holiday and my question
mr. Jones you mentioned the KKK Ku Klux
Klan are a bunch of idiots but what I
read in the past a lot of these the Ku
Klux Klan members were judges lawyers
doctors businessmen they wanted a bunch
of hayseeds and I think mr. cherry was a
fall guy and when was Mont Luther King's
home bombs not far from this date was at
least a few years before thank you yeah
his let me answer the question about the
Klan first and yes the Klan at the time
in the 30s 40s and 50s where there were
professionals there were judges there
were lawyers and remember one of our
great jurist Hugo black was at one point
a member of the Klan who later renounced
that but what we saw in Birmingham was
it not the Klan as a whole but there was
a group of what I call the more ignorant
Klansmen who only knew violence the
judges and the lawyers and people like
that I don't think we're in that
category but there were a group of folks
that all they could do and all they
couldn't respond
- were was with their hate was with
violence and those are the ones that I
think with the ignorant part of the Klan
that caused so much damage Martin Luther
King's home was bombed in Montgomery
Alabama about 90 miles south of here
in the 50s when he was a preacher at the
church down there that started the bus
boycott in Rosa Parks interestingly
after the Birmingham marches in the
spring of 1963 two weeks after those
marches were concluded dr. King's
brother the Reverend ad King who had a
church here in Birmingham at the time
his home was bombed just two weeks after
those marches we saw a lot more bombings
that summer here in Birmingham
Arthur Shores one of the great lawyers
his home was bombed not once but twice
that year so that that faction of the
Klan they were known as the Cahaba River
Bridge boys the violent faction of the
Klan were really kicking it into high
gear in the summer and fall of 1963 I
want to put one other event into
perspective because around the time of
the bombings 50 years ago dr. King was
sent to a Birmingham jail and he
received pressure from other ministers
in the Birmingham community and he wrote
a letter
can you explain well that was in the
spring of 1963 just so they started the
Birmingham marches in April of 1963
that's when dr. King was was arrested
interestingly Steve those Marxist people
forget sometimes those marches were
postponed on two different occasions
because people in Birmingham were
beginning to see change in November of
1962 they had voted to change the form
of government from a three-member
Commission to a mayor and city council
and and in just in February I believe it
was February of 63 there were elections
for the first city council of Birmingham
the first mayor of Birmingham in Bull
Connor was running for mayor and it was
thought that if the marches took place
it would might influence in a bad way of
that election when Bull Connor got in a
runoff with Albert Boutwell the marchers
were postponed again but as the marches
started after Bull Connor was defeated
dr. King decided he was going to go to
jail he and Reverend Abernathy went to
jail
and there had been a time that was
published a letter from some clergy that
was basically employing dr. King to just
wait to that Birmingham was beginning to
see changes to give the new city
government an opportunity to come and
make the changes necessary dr. King's
famous letter was essentially why we
can't wait it was a remarkable response
written on pieces scrap pieces of paper
newspaper
Paulette paper from the jail that was
snuck out by his lawyer Clarence Jones
and others that was then pieced together
a a lot of people think that that letter
got published immediately it didn't it
didn't really see very much light until
the summer of 1963 but today hands
stands I think as a testament as to one
of the great works of literature in
American history about the need for
action the need for peaceful action and
why you should not wait when you see
wrong so final question for you Doug
Jones what do you tell this generation
not old enough to remember what happened
fifty years ago and where we are today
as a country I tell them to be vigilant
to study their history to look and see
we we I don't think that the history of
the civil rights movement is taught at
schools like it should be black schools
white schools integrated schools it
doesn't matter people need to understand
the struggles because it was not only
dr. King it was the forces of good that
prevailed but you learn also from the
forces of evil because evil still exists
and today and as I said to the jury in
the chary case you know we had hope in
1963 the black community had a hope and
hope is a good thing and good things
never die and people like Bobby cherry
tried to kill that hope we still have
hope in this country today and our
children are the hope of our future and
our society is getting ever more diverse
in this country and it's not going to
change regardless of what we do with
immigration bills and things like that
and we need to make sure that we learn
those lessons and that we continue to
love respect and and and really
celebrate the diversity of this country
and embrace each other and that's the
lessons I think that is the lessons of
the past but as we're saying here in
that's the lessons for 50 years forward
not just backward Doug Jones responsible
for the prosecution of some of those
involved in the bombings that took place
50 years ago at the 16th Street Baptist
Church in Birmingham Alabama thanks very
much for being with us thank you Steve
enjoyed it and a reminder we are live
all day here on c-span threes American
history TV and you're looking at scenes
outside the 16th Street Baptist Church
which became a focal point of the civil
rights movement in the early and mid
1960s many attribute the bombing that
killed four little girls as one of the
moments that led to the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 and the Voting Rights Act of
1965 a reminder at three o'clock Central
Time 4:00 o'clock here in the East live
coverage of a ceremony that will include
comments by US Attorney General Eric
Holder and former secretary of state
condoleezza noon here on c-span threes
American history TV but earlier this
week as Congress paid tribute to those
four girls killed in the bombings here
is a 50 minute portion and this is a
live view by the way of exactly where
that bombing took place at 10:22 a.m.
Eastern Time 50 years ago Congress
paying tribute to those who lie